Природа стала мовчазною жертвою цієї війни.
Україна - одна з найзамінованіших країн світу, мабуть, найзамінованіша.
Збитки тільки від підриву Каховської ГЕС сягають 147 мільярдів гривень.
Україна втратила понад 14 кубічних кілометрів води.
Цього обсягу достатньо, щоб два дні поїти водою весь світ.
Загальна сума збитків вже перевищує 2,2 трильйони гривень.
Я вірю в те, що ми можемо довести ці всі злочини в міжнародних судах,
і ми можемо довести ці збитки.
Пане міністре, ми сьогодні поговоримо про шкоду, завдану довкіллю війною.
Чи можете оцінити, якою є поточна оцінка цієї шкоди в цифрах?
З перших днів повномасштабного вторгнення Державна екологічна інспекція
обраховує всі збитки, які рашисти наносять нашому довкіллю,
використовуючи сім нових методик.
На сьогоднішній день ми маємо вже інформацію про задокументовані
більше ніж 2900 таких випадків знищення нашого довкілля.
Фактично це злочини проти довкілля.
Загальна сума збитків вже перевищує 2,2 трильйони гривень.
Найбільшим випадком екоциду,
який вони зробили на нашій території,
це був підрив Каховської ГЕС.
Збитки тільки від підриву Каховської ГЕС і затоплення територій
сягають 147 мільярдів гривень.
На той момент, коли вони скоїли цей теракт,
це було 10% від збитків, які були обраховані на той момент.
Але я впевнений у тому, що ми будемо продовжувати цю роботу,
і всі ті випадки, які ще не обраховані,
будуть, відповідно, додані в загальний кошик збитків.
На жаль, руйнування і втрати не припинені сьогодні,
бо війна триває.
Але я впевнений у тому, що та робота, яка ведеться,
точно повинна дати змогу зафіксувати всі випадки,
задокументувати всі злочини,
тому що ми після нашої перемоги повинні виставити окупанту рахунок
за кожний клаптик зруйнованої української землі.
Яка наразі ситуація біля Каховської ГЕС?
Минуло вже майже півроку.
Які там зараз ви бачите наслідки?
Коли рашисти зробили цей теракт на Каховській ГЕС,
найбільша втрата, яка фактично відбулася,
це те, що річка Дніпро і, відповідно, Україна
втратила понад 14 кубічних кілометрів води.
Це колосальний обсяг води.
Просто для розуміння цього обсягу достатньо,
щоб два дні поїти водою весь світ.
Це колосальні цифри, колосальний обсяг води.
До чого це призвело?
У першу чергу, це призвело до руйнування інфраструктурних об'єктів,
до руйнування життя людей.
Це призвело до затоплення великої кількості лісів,
50% з яких скоріш за все вже вмруть, тому що вони були затоплені.
Дуже сильно пошкоджена була територія
деяких наших національних парків, відповідно, Рамсарських угідь.
Але ми розуміємо, що 14 кубічних кілометрів прісної води
точно не пройшли непомітно, потрапивши в Чорне море.
Відбулися процеси опріснення,
які скоріш за все самостійно вирівняються пізніше,
але це дуже серйозний вплив.
Велика кількість відходів потрапила в Чорне море.
Була інформація про те, що понад 150 тонн мастила потрапило у воду.
Це колосальне забруднення, яке спостерігали і на березі річки Дніпро,
тому що нафтопродуктову плівку просто прибивало до берега.
Відповідно, її треба було потім збирати.
Ми повинні сьогодні пам'ятати, що осушення дна Каховського водосховища -
це потенційні процеси опустелювання і процеси розвитку
інвазивних видів рослин, які потенційно можуть з'явитися
на дні Каховського водосховища.
Інвазивні види є більш агресивними, ніж ті види, які характерні,
відповідно вони будуть захоплювати екосистему значно швидше.
Щоб цього не відбулося, працівники наших національних парків,
які знаходяться в безпосередній близькості,
провели заходи із залуження частини дна Каховського водосховища,
фактично, засадили його різнотрав'ям для того,
щоб у першу чергу не допустити інвазію,
в другу чергу для того, щоб зберегти чашу Каховського водосховища,
щоб вона не руйнувалася без води.
Втрати насправді колосальні.
За моїм проханням до нас прибула місія UNEP.
Ця спеціальна місія була організована спеціально для обрахунку
і фіксації збитків від наслідків цього теракту.
Це були представники, більше 20 представників майже з 20 країн світу.
Вони працювали кілька місяців, наразі є опублікований звіт.
Ми розуміємо, що в цьому звіті не відображені всі збитки довкіллю,
тому що там ситуація вкрай небезпечна.
Навіть коли співробітники Служби надзвичайних ситуацій
рятували людей, рашисти продовжували гатити з артилерії,
і навіть деякі працівники Національної поліції,
Державної служби надзвичайних ситуацій були або травмовані,
або навіть загинули.
Тому в рашистів немає нічого святого, вони не зупиняються.
Є інформація про те, що в результаті підриву Каховської ГЕС
навіть потенційно зникли ендемічні види тварин.
Тобто це ті тваринки, які жили в єдиному місці на землі.
Є такий маленький гризун, ємуранчик, який жив тільки там, в Херсонській області.
Більше такого в світі не було.
Підрив Каховської ГЕС потенційно знищив цей ендемічний вид.
І фактично планета втратила ще одного представника фауни.
В природі нічого не проходить безслідно.
І втрата одного виду може призвести до втрати багатьох інших видів.
Як це вплине далі вже на розвиток,
екологічний розвиток і відновлення екосистем, покаже час.
Але наша задача сьогодні - не залишити без уваги жоден випадок
знищення нашого довкілля та дати світові інструменти,
щоб обраховувати ці збитки внаслідок війни.
Тому що якщо ми сьогодні залишимо це без уваги,
ми не зможемо зробити так, щоб кожен майбутній агресор,
майбутня війна обраховувалася не тільки у вартості зброї
і не тільки у вартості воєнних дій.
Кожен наступний агресор у будь-якому куточку світу
повинен розуміти, що війна - це дорого.
І дорого - тому що довкілля теж має свою ціну.
Ви сказали, що Каховська АЕС і вся ця територія зараз знаходиться в зоні бойових дій.
Але які є плани відновити цю екологію після того, як це стане можливо?
І скільки це коштуватиме?
Насправді нині немає достеменних підрахунків,
скільки буде коштувати відновити цю територію.
Є території, які навіть за будь-які кошти світу ми не відновимо.
Я сьогодні кажу про водно-болотні угіддя,
Рамсарські угіддя, частину національних парків,
які формувала природа багато-багато років.
А рашисти сьогодні або гатять з артилерії,
або запускають ракети, або знищують танками ці цінні території.
Тому сказати, що треба для того, щоб його відновити -
треба просто скоріш за все цій природі не заважати.
Ми повинні з вами пам'ятати, що величезна кількість
територій нашої країни сьогодні замінована.
Україна - одна з найзамінованіших країн світу, мабуть, найзамінованіша.
Близько 30% території країни є потенційно замінованою.
На розмінування піде дуже багато років.
І відновлювати довкілля ми можемо тільки після того,
як зможемо забезпечити безпеку тих людей, які це будуть робити.
Або дати природі тишу, щоб вона змогла самовідновитися.
Я впевнений у тому, що ми можемо відновити наші ліси.
Ми можемо посадити нові саджанці, нові сіянці.
Але ми не можемо прискорити час.
Тому що той ліс, який ріс десятки років, не виросте за один день.
Ми це не прискоримо.
Тому будемо робити все можливе.
Але зараз вкрай важливо те, щоб наші Збройні сили
все-таки відкинули орків до конституційних кордонів нашої країни.
Вигнали їх за межі кордонів.
І після того ми вже будемо говорити про дорахування тих збитків,
які ми ще не дорахували.
І далі будемо думати, як виходити із ситуації відновлення нашої живої природи.
Хоча, наприклад, випадки з мертвими дельфінами,
а у нас їх зафіксовано вже близько тисячі тільки офіційно.
Хоча за неофіційними даними таких випадків може бути десятки тисяч.
Ми сьогодні говоримо з партнерами про потенційне будівництво
реабілітаційного центру для дельфінів
або в Одеській, або в Херсонській області.
Тобто там, де це буде можливо.
Тому що ми розуміємо, що природа стала мовчазною жертвою цієї війни.
І ми повинні сьогодні все-таки їй допомогти,
реабілітуючи тварин або відновлюючи екосистеми.
А сама ГЕС буде відновлена?
Дивіться, питання дуже дискусійне насправді.
І я можу вам сказати одне, що в першу чергу важливо
забезпечити там безпеку і взагалі можливість щось зробити.
У мене, наприклад, немає актуальної інформації взагалі
щодо конкретного пошкодження.
Тобто, що саме було пошкоджено, як пошкоджено,
чи можливо її відновити в тому вигляді, в якому вона є.
Тому я впевнений, що треба залишити час експертам
для того, щоб це питання дуже детально вивчити.
Давайте про злочини. Генпрокуратура повідомила,
що зафіксувала понад 200 воєнних злочинів проти довкілля.
Як ви оцінюєте: що є злочином, а що може бути супутня втрата?
Дивіться, ми сьогодні дуже плідно працюємо з Офісом генерального прокурора.
Нещодавно ми навіть провели міжнародний спільний форум United for Justice, United for Nature.
Ми сьогодні шукаємо певні шляхи кооперації,
тому що екологічна інспекція може зафіксувати злочини.
Ті майже 2900 злочинів проти довкілля, які зафіксувала екологічна інспекція,
так чи інакше потрапляють до Генеральної прокуратури,
де вони вже формують кримінальні справи.
Важливо, що рік тому генеральний прокурор Андрій Костін
анонсував відкриття Офісу прокурора Міжнародного кримінального суду в Україні.
Це допоможе нашим правникам, прокурорам правильно сформувати ті справи,
які спочатку повинні вистояти в наших судах,
а потім вже бути захищеними в Міжнародному кримінальному суді.
Це важливо в першу чергу для того, щоб весь світ визнав ті збитки,
які сьогодні рашисти наносять в тому числі нашим екосистемам.
Я хочу нагадати, що було започатковано Міжнародний реєстр збитків.
Невід'ємною складовою цього реєстру є ті злочини проти довкілля, які ми сьогодні фіксуємо.
Я вірю в те, що використовуючи сьогодні нові методи
і фактично роблячи це спільно з Офісом генерального прокурора
вперше в історії людства фіксацію збитків довкілля унаслідок війни,
використовуючи вперше методики оцінки збитків унаслідок війни,
ми започаткуємо той процес, який у будь-якому випадку
дасть нам змогу відшкодувати втрати наших екосистем.
Але для того, щоб це вважалося злочином,
там же ще й інші критерії, що це навмисне пошкодження довкілля.
Як ви це робите?
Дуже гарне питання, але можу сказати вам одне,
що наша задача - це виконати ті завдання,
які сьогодні перед нами стоять, і відповідно вже передати Офісу генерального прокурора.
Тому що юристи і правники повинні зробити свою роботу.
Але ми розуміємо, що вже сьогодні вкрай важливо
зробити кілька таких пілотних кримінальних справ,
пройти через суд, в тому числі через Міжнародний кримінальний суд,
для того, щоб зрозуміти, де могли бути помилки під час документування,
під час збирання доказів, під час обрахунку,
під час формування тих самих справ, які відправляються в суд.
І я впевнений у тому, що відповідь на ваше запитання
буде після того, як кілька кейсів стануть реальністю.
Зараз досвіду з такими випадками ще немає в міжнародних судах.
Які у вас очікування, який може бути результат?
Я вірю в те, що ми можемо довести ці всі злочини
в міжнародних судах, і ми можемо довести ці збитки.
На конференції United for Justice, United for Nature,
яка була в цьому році в Києві,
яку, до речі, відвідала велика кількість міністрів довкілля з інших країн,
ми презентували драфт довкільної декларації.
Це декларація про готовність започаткувати платформу,
яка об'єднає всі країни, які бажають до неї доєднатися,
і не тільки на політичному рівні, а й на експертному, на науковому, на інших рівнях.
Ми вже не сумніваємося, і весь світ не сумнівається,
хто є насправді агресором, хто прийшов на чужу землю,
хто намагається нищити все українське.
Це Путін, який своїми злочинними наказами сьогодні руйнує все, включаючи наше довкілля.
Тому вкрай важливо, що ми не повинні вже сьогодні
це доказувати, але ми повинні сьогодні провести верифікацію,
експертну верифікацію, отримати політичне схвалення,
доєднати якомога більше країн світу до цього процесу
і ухвалити спільне виважене рішення,
і вже далі проводити відповідну адвокацію та стягування збитків.
Якщо поглянути на те, що відбувається зараз у цій війні,
і на цю кількість злочинів, які зараз кояться,
наскільки ці справи про злочини проти довкілля важливі?
Чи на фоні смертей людей це вважається менш значущим?
Справа в тому, що ми повинні зважати на всі аспекти і всі наслідки цієї війни.
Ще раз підкреслюю, збитки довкіллю обраховуються вперше.
Якщо казати про фіксацію взагалі оцих злочинів проти довкілля,
то їхня вартість у деяких випадках може бути або дорівнювати,
або навіть перевищувати ті збитки, які завдаються інфраструктурі.
Я з вами повністю погоджую, що життя людей - це вкрай важливо, це перше.
Перше, на що треба зважати і чим повинні займатися органи генерального прокурора.
Але ще раз кажу, важливо зафіксувати
абсолютно всі злочини і абсолютно всі збитки.
Комплексно оцінюючи всі ці збитки,
ми робимо крок для запобігання майбутнім війнам
або збройним конфліктам у будь-якій точці світу.
Пане міністре, дякую за інтерв'ю.
Дякую вам.